speaking of Good Deeds we're going to
begin this hour with a story we first
brought you a few weeks ago and with
that come with that update comes a big
surprise call it a super surprise you
might remember Shakira Autry she's the
Buffalo New York mother who helped
rescue a developmentally disabled man
who was trapped in a blizzard at
Christmas she brought the stranger Joey
white into her home and she cared for
that man like he was family 911 to
emergency calls because it was so
dangerous outside so she eventually
pleaded for help on Facebook as Joey's
frostbitten fingers worsened strangers
helped to take Joey to the hospital
almost two days after Shakira and her
boyfriend took him in here's what's
happened since we first told that story
hi Joey 42 days after she and her
boyfriend saved his life how
Kyra Autry reunited with a visibly
emotional Joey white you miss me I miss
you
Joey who is developmentally disabled has
been in the hospital because nearly all
of his fingers were amputated due to
frostbite he keeps screaming hope I
don't know what to do since we first
reported the Christmas story about how
Shakira and her boyfriend Trent alls Jr
rescued and cared for Joey in their
buffalo home after he was caught in a
blizzard New York's Governor Kathy hokel
honored her and on top of that the
Buffalo Bills invited Shakira Trent and
their kids to join the wife of the
general manager and the wife of the head
coach as their guests at the final
regular season football game yeah we all
love you we right here because they
cared for him like their own family your
we had a surprise for them there's
Shakira she thinks she's here to meet
with her boss and lucky for us Trent
just happened to be with her
eyes
it's you how are you Hi how are you
hi Shakira yes for everything you have
done yes for joey yes for the world who
feels just a sense of goodness about
what you did okay the NFL
saw the story wow and they are going to
send you to the Super Bowl in Phoenix
Arizona
the Super Bowl I see
now how are you gonna get there
um
I hope they got a flight for me well all
right so Delta Airlines heard about what
you did and they want to fly you there
wow okay Delta thank you I appreciate it
going by yourself
um
I only got one ticket so it looked like
it you want to go to the Super Bowl man
of course he want to go to the Super
Bowl got you a ticket as well appreciate
this this I mean a lot you know why it
means a lot because Trent played High
School football and dreamed of playing
in the NFL have you ever been to a Super
Bowl no you only dream about those
things man those don't really come true
for most people that means a lot you're
going my man it was Trent who tracked
into that blizzard to bring Joey into
their home this is the first time he's
spoken publicly about what happened that
morning when Joey came and knocked on
the door it was kind of like five six in
the morning and I thought it was no I
didn't think nothing I'm like man don't
open that door and then she came with me
said we really have to go help them make
you please go help him because whatever
was your parents so I went out there and
then it was just bad and the first thing
I noticed was his hands basically like
real huge ice balls I think what the two
of you did was just so human I probably
would have never went out there unless
me being completely honest so that is a
lot of her like I said if she want to
say she said I probably wouldn't have
went out there but I'm glad she did
because
it alarms from me like it could be
anybody that you love has this changed
you as a person I would say yeah I only
want to help people when it's convenient
for me now I try to even if it's just
saying good morning or saying the
smallest thing to people to me like that
goes a long way compared to just walking
by a person what was your reaction when
you heard that all of his fingers were
amputated except for one that hurt it
did that hurt because initially
something they were going to be able to
save them
and I cried like a baby in the bed why
did you cry because I
I tried to prevent it that's from
happening you know I don't know anything
about frostbite I didn't know his hands
were going to turn black I didn't know
any of those things I've never seen it
ever in my life he was having a medical
emergency right in front of you and I
tried
earlier this week Trent went to see Joey
remember me Joey who is undergoing
extensive rehab they told him that they
were going to the Super Bowl and he was
excited Trent's Focus though was on
helping the 64 year old with basic needs
like picking the remote up off the floor
and eating the kindness
continue we at CBS were just privileged
that you welcomed us into your home and
allowed us to tell the story I
appreciate it I finally got to meet you
in real life you see what I say wait
yeah I see you on TV you're the real guy
look who it is
man I love them some more exciting
updates to share yesterday Joey was
released from the hospital after 45 days
to start what is going to be a long road
to recovery at an area rehab facility
and their kids got a surprise of their
own Justin Kyrie and Tristan are going
on a free four-day vacation for their
first ever trip to Disney World thanks
to JetBlue Airways and the vacation year
vacations the family plans to head there
for spring break in April now that is
exciting for the non-sports fans out
there and you look at you you're
existing in real life I love that high
five you're a real dude that's awesome a
great surprise we had a blast doing it
and uh go ahead I was gonna say it
really is just this lesson though to
help like a little small thing I know
they're saying it was such a big deal to
go out into the snow but it was such a
small thing to help one person that
story has gotten me from the very
beginning that it's just a moment for
all of us to remember what a small
gesture can do and the difference it can
make and it keeps reverberating it's
amazing you said it beautiful this story
hopefully helps us say next time I see
it I might step don't just walk that's
the payoff that's the takeaway to what
Shakira Did yeah love you lady and then
enjoy the Super Bowl and then maybe
David begno show up and tell your story
that's right hey you never know